hey everyone it's my vatos and welcome
to the order flows market analysis for
Monday September 11 2017 market opened
up Sunday nights
equity markets and we jumped higher and
we continued that during the day gold
sold off a bit were down about 20 bucks
I believe crude oil was back up about 48
bucks
so basically you know the hurricane Irma
hit landfall on Sunday afternoon in
Florida wasn't as bad as you know people
on the counterfeit news network or
claiming it was going to be
unfortunately you know so I mean that
was good I mean if there's any good
takeaway from this tragedy but anyway
the disclaimer this presentation is for
educational informational purposes only
should not be considered a solicitation
to buy or sell a futures contract or
make any other type of investment
decision future train contains
substantial risk and it's not for every
investor and investor could potentially
lose all or more than the initial
investment risk capital as money that
could be lost without jeopardizing One
SPY nancial security or lifestyle only
risk capital should be used for trading
no way those were sufficient risk
capital should consider training past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results tools I use
in this presentation are the order flows
trader which is the volume footprint
chart the Delta scalper and the price
rejector Delta scalper and price
rejector are two additional order flow
tools Delta scalper reads Delta price
rejector reads the actual order flow
inside of the bar so without further ado
let's jump into the markets first off
I'll talk about crude today okay so
crude oil it was it was quite
interesting I'm coming in to around the
nine o'clock time we were trading lower
in crude here you can see you can see us
going lower here this is a 20
all negative Delta's in here as the
markets selling off you got a couple
positive Delta's but more or less even
just all negative deltas under pressure
the entire day until you start coming in
here so 8:20 you know you got a couple
positive deltas couple up bars there you
can see then we make this new low here
844 you have the divergence you've got
the negative the positive Delta has got
the Delta scalper kicking in so on this
low what do you got you've got positive
Delta 500 which is strong Delta scalp or
giving you a buy signal you got the
divergence and then
are up Delta a little bit less its 356
still it's positive it's a nice it's a
nice positive Delta actually but then
you run into this bar and what do you
got you got a single print in the bar
you've got a ratio bounce high
indicating stopping wrong price
rejection up here you got a smallish
Delta 79 so what look bullish here I
said you know you got Delta scalper you
got a nice positive Delta next bar it
it's still up but Delta's weaker still a
nice Delta though but this bar 79 Delta
positive something that's that's kind of
weak I mean that's as borderline neutral
if it's around 50 I'd say it's neutral
but 79 is still you know it's it's on
the weak side and you've got a couple
bearish signs up here you got point of
control up near the top you've got you
know the bearish ratio
you've got the single print why do I
mean you know why is this point of
control P to the top bearish well you
can see up here right what's the point
of control point of control is the point
in the bar that has the most volume okay
now I start looking when I got point of
control up near the top what I'm looking
for is the volume around that area so
you got 323 500 100 okay 100 is not that
great but 500 300 yeah 800 Lots up here
at the top of this bar so I know that
there's supply coming in here there's
sellers up here happy to lean on the
market so to speak you know work the
offers to sort of sit there and stop any
move that's really going further okay so
you know you got this volume up here I
could start trading higher your trade
only for all right where's the
additional buying coming and you just
bought you know buyers bought 500 they
bought 300 why aren't there buying
anything else up here and taking the
market higher instead these people are
sort of caught off sides and the market
starts trading lower you know people
talk about trap traders you know traders
being stuck in positions in this case
people are long and wrong and the market
starts ticking down they become sellers
start hitting these bids down here and
you take off the lows now you get down
to this new low at 902 you do have a
positive Delta 27 it's it's kind of
neutral
next bar strong positive Delta 677 y'all
scalper kicks off you got a bar here
imbalance in balancing balancing balance
and balance five imbalances next bar
very strong positive Delta as well 562
next bar 1100 so you're coming down into
the slow I mean look at the
these two lows are actually kind of
similar but similar but slightly
different okay and I wanna get into it
in a second here so here you got Delta
you just go back one bar 7 67 281 140 so
it's it's Delta net selling is getting
weaker it's not as strong anymore it's
kind of lightening up you get down here
it's aggressive buyers now so it's a -
700 - 281 - 140 plus 500 plus 356 now
you got a delta scalper you got the
divergence it looks like hey we can
start to go but you're not seeing the
follow-through buying what you want to
see is still strong aggressive buying in
here instead you got kind of a weak
number 79
you got some bearish signs up here at
the point of control with the bearish
ratio with the single print and then
obviously the next bar is negative Delta
400 so you know sellers have come up you
could sort of see I'm creeping in here
you get that feeling this one definitely
is obvious so even if you're long here
when you see this bar you know this bar
should be you know learning you hey you
know this might not be working out this
bar definitely so you know you could
might get out a little bit earlier
rather than have it stop you out but you
know it maybe it could have stopped you
out but then you get down here it's
starting to see something a little bit
similar you see the declining Delta -
400 - 137 then turns positive positive
27 it's kind of neutral but then BOOM
677 positive Delta Delta scalper kicks
off you got mine imbalances do you have
buying imbalances in here this quarter
no this one you got one but you got it
sort of in an area where you expect it
to be you know on green candles
generally you know the bottom price
against the bottom bid against the
bottom offer the second bottom offer is
generally going to give you an imbalance
just as you know on red candles you
often get it up here you know the the
top offer against the top bid you know
the second bid so that's that's in this
area you expect it to see but this bar
again you got multiple imbalances for
Plus this one down here you got the
single print you got the ratio you got
the Delta scalper so what's different
all right you got the divergence you got
the divergence you got the Delta scalper
you got the Delta scalper you got the
positive Delta
of Delta in this bar necklace bear it's
a weaker Delta and X bars are stronger
Delta this party have the Delta scalper
like you had here you got the bullish
ratio you got a single print next bar
still positive Delta next bar and this
one is negative so this one you know
even though I do think you know this one
was worth the shot it's worth a shot
anytime you got a reason to buy off the
low it's probably worth it if it's a
legitimate reason it's good enough I
mean you could sort of see it fall apart
here okay before it does fall apart but
this one there's no reason to be getting
out of this trade no this first one yeah
there is a reason here I mean I talked
about this bars a bearish looking bar
but this one is bullish you know again
it's you see a nice positive Delta you
know it's a nice up candle point of
control in the middle which is kind of
neutral next bar as well
a thousand delta very strong so it
really starts to look like we are going
to start to pull away from this low but
again you know this these two bars are
sorry this for if you go here here here
here these four bars look a lot stronger
than you know these four bars there's
just a little bit more on these four
than on the previous four and what
happens is you get a down candle here
negative Delta 200 okay it's not the end
of the world this bar here negative
Delta 236 okay but the bar turned up now
this is key why you have negative Delta
well you got supportive buying four
hundred 200 300 175 146 so I know that
there was selling in here I mean you
have this imbalance at 322 honestly if
you didn't have you know if this was
just like a normal number here we'll
call it I don't know 100 and something
you'd have either a small negative Delta
or slightly positive Delta but again
here just because you got one bar with
negative Delta and it's a red candle
doesn't mean all the trade is over I got
to get out no you know watch what's
happening let it unfold before your eyes
like I said you know this one you had a
few more things you got the bearish
ratio you got the single print port of
control but near the top you don't have
any of that in this bar you don't have
any bear signs other than the negative
Delta but again just because you got one
bar with negative Delta doesn't mean
it's seen in the world this bar even
though it's got negative Delta there's a
reason why the Delta is negative he had
support of buying and in fact
seeing how it turned back up here and
closed higher is actually bullish next
bar positive Delta next bar positive
Delta positive Delta so at this point
you know you should still be in this
position you shouldn't be looking to cut
it there's absolutely no reason to be
cut in this position and what happens is
the market just you know starts working
its way back up up up you get a nice
buying and balance here on the way up
then you run into this area up in here
stack buying imbalance and then you just
start going sideways this bar you got
porn controlling at the top you got the
Delta scalper kicking in you know if
you're in that position you might want
to think about cutting it honestly I
would have its trading forty seven
seventy five you know and you know were
you long from your long from down here
at I don't know what that is 47 you know
fifteen forty seven sixteen and it
trades all the way up to forty seven
seventy five seventy six so that's what
that's a sixty cent move so in the first
trade maybe you lost 10 ticks second
trade you're getting back sixty ticks
you know that's what it's about
you know having a good healthy risk
reward ratio you know eventually circled
around and did make new highs but again
you know I'm not saying that you know
here this is the area that you would
have gotten out of honestly you start
seeing it coming down like this starting
stringing together a bunch of negative
Delta's strong one 600 459 305 845 you
got some bearish signs in here you know
this is where you'd be looking to get
out of on that trade not I'm gonna hold
it and you know I'm not going to be
someone say oh yeah you could have sold
bought it off that low then right up
here is where you'd be selling it no I
mean come on that's a bit the phrase of
the day disingenuous he always watched I
always see these political analysts use
that term disingenuous but anyway you
know that was the trade that was to be
had there in the in the in the ones that
crude oil and like I said you know the
first one you know I think you know nine
times out of ten I would have taken that
trade but then reading this this in here
you know the order flow you know that's
the sign to get out or you know it maybe
missed that sign you get stopped out
okay you know loss has happened in
trading okay
I mean
I don't wanna discourage people but you
know what you know part of trading is
part of being a good trader is
understanding the markets not going in
your direction and you got to get out of
the trade now the British us and a
British pound this is the the euro
currency and you know there's something
very interesting very similar to you
know crude right let's just talk about
this crude so what do you have here why
did this one work and this one didn't I
said you know you had a bunch of other
bullish signs but again you get your
divergence no ratio here alright so
there's not that trade setup and here
you got the trade sup you got your
divergence and your ratio on the next
bar obviously adding the Delta scalper
to it is a bonus as well and the
imbalances and you know and everything
else but you know this is a trade setup
I talked about almost every video you
know I show you again I don't pick out
charts from 100 different markets you
know they pick out the ones where it
worked I sure I talked about the same
markets pretty much every day crude oil
ESPYs euro currency bonds five years you
know I stick to those markets and you
know did you see the same thing
appearing over and over at some point
you gotta say hey you know maybe there's
something to it I mean that's why you
see these other softwares coming out
sierracharts is starting to add ratios
in there but what's the point is just
adding a number you have to understand
how to use it right you know my software
takes it a step further and you know
really breaks it down for you until
what's a good number what's a bad number
or what's a nice a bad number what's a
normal number so again your euro
currency this is eight range this is
2:00 in the morning
you've got your divergence the positive
Delta but no ratio look to the next bar
you got your ratio you also have your
Delta scalper so just as in the crude
you had your divergence and your ratio
in the next bar you also got your Delta
scupper this time it's in the bar on the
low on the crude it was on the bar right
afterwards and again you're on your low
this red line is your low today now you
did have a delta scalper sell here right
as you're coming down into the low but
again you know even if you're short you
get in the my signal here so maybe you
just you know sort of scratch this trade
or maybe lose a tick or maybe make a
tick depending on how adept you are to
trading and so what happens is
you're at your low and what happens you
keep rallying rallying rally all the way
up to new highs
you know from 120 you know what is that
you know 1 2003 or 4 all the way up to
120 you know 30 up here where you'd be
getting out so again you know these
trade setups happen every day
in the markets you know if you're not
using order flow you know you're really
missing out on a lot of information out
there now again you know is there
anything else you could pick up here
yeah you got some smallish delta numbers
here honestly you know you delta
scalpers picking up the changes in the
delta do you need the delta scalper to
pick this up no I mean you could analyze
that yourself but you know if you could
have a tool that will help you analyze
it then it's just going to make your
trading a bit better okay so this is the
bonds talk about bonds bonds were you
know since you know from about 6:00 in
the morning the bonds were dead quiet
but in just watching the bonds it's very
slow-moving market during the European
session very quiet wasn't until US
session came in that they really started
to sell off but you know so under
pressure all morning you see here you
got you know nor is it good this one's a
bad print but here you know from where
are we 620 here look at all this red all
negative deltas as you're selling off
boom boom boom down here again you got a
ratio bullish ratio you got a selling
example us selling imbalance right on
the low got a buying a balance on the
way back up
you know I thought maybe you know this
market could pop up here next bar it
takes up about 3 or 3 ticks you know
from where it opened before continuing
on down negative Delta though we only
see negative Delta like this and you
know just sort of I sort of have this
lingering feeling they're still selling
left in this market you know so I'm not
surprised that we came out made a new
low you know I thought maybe we could
get a pop up you know would have been
beautiful to get you know positive
gulten here maybe I'd be really more
interested in it again you got that
selling and balance on that low but then
the market popped back up rallied I said
the only this is a yet this green arrow
there it's hard to see on this chart but
there's a green arrow there which tells
me you know it's a short-term buy and it
does pop up a little bit like I said you
know three three ticks more or less once
this new bar started but then it came
right back down thousand- Delta a
thousand negative Delta nine hundred he
just keeps selling off selling off
there's not any reason to be buying down
in here as you're making these new lows
new lows here you've got the this is the
price rejecter okay that's its price
rejecter on the low of the day it's kind
of small Delta I'd like to see a
positive Delta you know it's it did eat
it back or did go back from minus 988 so
minus a thousand Delta to basically
neutral okay which is a bullish sign you
know can you take that trade yeah you
can take that trade I do like that I do
like how that is it's just unfortunate
that you know next bar again you'll
started popping up but then it just got
slammed again minus 600 Delta so I mean
this was maybe the only really you know
if you're thinking of buying you know
this one down here is more of a
short-term thing this one earlier with
the buying and selling the balance on
that low but this one you know if you're
looking more of a maybe we're going to
really bounce off this one yeah I can
see that I can see that trade I could
see that it didn't it just failed it
made new lows cats gets down in here
this is the Delta surge actually right
here also didn't work out then you get
down here into this low you've got but
you know it's interesting positive Delta
is all down in here so you're seeing you
know aggressive buying off these those
other people are trying to buy off these
lows you don't think this markets gonna
go higher that's why you got all these
positive Delta's three hundred seventeen
hundred twelve hundred yeah it's a
sooner or later you're hanging around
the lows even making new lows with
positive Delta this markets going to
bounce now the extent of the bounce is
gonna be another story but it does
bounce okay and you got your divergence
here finally and your ratio in the next
bar next bar is up got a couple buying
imbalances
it's ready you 130 thought this time and
you're thinking honey now we're gonna
get a move up to you know 12 or
something what happens you just sort of
go sideways you got to side by side
opponent controls coming into the cache
close and Delta scalper gives you a sell
so you have a move yeah it's kind of a
half-hearted move about 1 1 2 3 4 ticks
more or less nothing major and in the
evening session just going sideways
still all right so again I'll talk about
a couple quick charts here in the Delta
scalper okay default setting seven one
one two five two it's a union Renko
chart on gold and the reason why I'm
showing you this again it's not this
just cherry-pick charts you know someone
posted a message actually earlier today
saying hey why don't you show this you
know signals being generated in real
time well you know I've got about 30
charts open up I say no 30 about 40
charts open up I would literally have to
screen shot every single market it's not
possible unless it was just like one
market and I'm screenshotting it for the
entire trading session okay and then I
have to go back and edit all that so I
don't know I don't have the time to go
in through and edit everything like that
and just you know pick it out when it's
happening you know that's why I prefer
to do these and just you know show it to
you know I say after the fact but you
know after the trading day you know when
I have time to do this and during the
day I've got other going on I
bother things going on you know besides
you know to sit here and make videos all
day it's not easy you know it's not easy
you know I try to get a video out every
day and it sometimes I can't because I
got just I've got a family and I got
three kids and you know with with three
kids it's so hot it's a lot of work in
addition to doing everything else that I
got to do during the day but anyway it's
just easier for me to show it like this
okay so this is the Gold chart a couple
small cells early in the morning and
nice by rally here then this beautiful
the high of the day up here you know
that there's our 4:00 in the morning you
know catches this move from 40 you know
42 down to 30
six down in here you get the buy signal
this buy fails this buy you know how it
works out here then again another
another nice trade from 38 and a half
boom boom boom all the way down into the
into the clothes so yeah it's a you know
and even in the evening session as well
you getting some signals but I mean look
at that you could be happy with this
move yeah you would but what if you also
had a move like this of course you'd be
happy you know again that that's this
the that's the Union wrinkle chart and
you know how does it look on a couple
other charts honestly I know Dax was
pretty decent I think as well you didn't
wrinkle chart in the Dax gold one was
nice you wrinkle nothing early you got a
nice cell here a nice buy here kind of
an area you're spinning your wheels then
you get another's by here shoots up here
the cell fails so that was a nice nice
result in the in the Dax excuse me just
Nasdaq on it show you this I don't know
who you know people like to really push
the limits but this is a 233 tick chart
in NQ which is not something I would
advocate trading but still if you're
trading it you know you gotta be very
quick in and out in and out when it
trades not working out email but you
still getting some decent trades you
know here here here you know little
things I don't know what your profit
potential is you know here's a nice
trend here here's a nice little trend
here again you know people are training
a 233 tick chart which is very fast
chart especially for you know markets
like Nasdaq and they'll be like yeah you
know I got stopped out here why you
getting stopped out it gives you a move
here comes back gives you another move
here then it fails you know I think
they're trying to get like get in here
and get out you know up here it doesn't
make sense yeah your tween a 233 chick
chart you're gonna get a lot of signals
alright so don't try and over hold it
you know there's no that I got in here
and I'm on there to the next cell signal
well you
you you know then at that point you just
want to just throw out your your stops
altogether which is not a good idea but
you know you're trading if you're
hitting and run trader day trader scalp
announcing day trader scalper you're
just looking for the short-term
direction you're looking for the next
three or four or five six ticks you're
not looking for you know the next two or
three points you know over the next two
hours and in a 233 tick chart if you're
doing that you should be trading a
different type of chart different time
duration completely and just really
quick you know the Delta search you know
people I don't know you know love it or
hate it it's a decent indicator people
that don't understand order flow don't
understand the deltas Delta and how to
use it so this is Delta surge this is in
the dax this morning gives you this nice
buy here at 2:44 this is 12400 rallies
up right off this high 12 450 so that's
a 40 point move in the in the dax again
you got a little sell here
you got another sell here and Delta
surge you can download for free on my
website just you know you just sign up
for it you just got to enter your email
click submit and you could get it for
free honestly I don't know why else and
still people you know some reason not
big fans of it but you know this is
again Nasdaq 8 range chart you got a
nice you know buy here sell here then
you got this buy your training 59 70 and
rallies up to 59 90 something up here
you know so say you sell it on the way
back down here from 70 up to 90 that's
20 points 20 pool points in the Nasdaq
you get a cell signal here sells off you
got the cell signal here people will say
oh yeah I took the trade and it failed
look you know they don't you know say
they dad this trader at this trade they
want to complain about this one but to
each their own so anyway to learn more
about order flow trading software and
how you can get it go to order feels
calm
and to learn more about the Delta
scalper go to Delta scalper comm so
thanks everyone have a great day and
I'll catch you tomorrow bye-bye